>>Kelly Norton: I'm Kelly Norton. I'm the
tech lead for the Speed Tracer open source
project.
Now before, before I get started in earnest,
I just wanna ask a quick question which is:
how many people attended my talk by a similar
name last year? Anyone? Oh, cool. Awesome.
>>voice in audience: [inaudible]
>>Kelly Norton: Oh, awesome. Yeah. So, and
I, yeah a lot of people watched it on the
Web.
So, I'm gonna do things a-a little bit different
this year. Last year I talked about performance
tips and I told you what GWT, all the tools
in GWT do to help you make your apps faster.
This year I'm gonna do two things different.
The first thing is I'm not just gonna talk
about GWT development, I'm actually gonna
broaden the scope a little bit and just talk
about developing Web front-ends. The reason
will be obvious to you as I go through this,
so if you're writing your apps in JavaScript
or Java this talk will be of interest to you.
The second thing is, instead of giving you
a-a bunch of tips and-and telling you all
the new things in GWT to make your apps faster,
instead I'm gonna concentrate on this tool
Speed Tracer. The reasoning there is that
I-I truly believe that by showing you this
tool, it actually encaps-encapsulates more
tips in it than I can possibly tell you about
in an hour here on stage.
And the-the secret is, that much of the stuff
that I said last year came directly from Speed
Tracer, which wasn't released at the time.
However, if you absolutely are gonna be demandin'
your money back if you don't get tips about
performance, at least a day's worth, there's
a lot to see and hear at Google I/O, including
a number of talks today in this room and a
talk tomorrow.
In fact there's so much going on performance-wise,
I-I just took it upon myself to call it "the
(secret) front-end performance series."
One more bit of administration. If you're
interested in the live waving of this, that
is you want to take notes, have conversations,
ask questions while this session is happening
and after, jot down that URL quickly and,
and join in the wave.
[pause]
Alright. Let's get started.
So I told you what I'm not gonna talk about
and told you what other people were gonna
talk about. Now let me actually tell you what
I'm gonna talk about.
So the plan today is first we're gonna start.
Now when I do a performance talk I always
like to start by justifying why performance
matters.
Now that's kind of preachin' to-to the choir
right? I mean you're at a Google conference
in a session about performance. Google has
historically cared a lot about performance,
but I-I'd like to simplify the argument a
little bit and focus on one particular aspect
of performance in applications.
After we do that, hopefully I will have convinced
you; you'll stick around; and I'll spend most
of the time from there on out showing you
Speed Tracer. Giving you a-a test drive and
then we'll actually after that jump into a
few specific examples; scenarios that we've
had to tackle both internal and external to
Google, where we've actually used Speed Tracer
and found some of our own performance problems
and fortunately fixed them.
After that, you'll be so thrilled, you'll
wanna hear about new features; of course I'll
tell you about those and since we started
a little bit early, hopefully we'll have time
for even a-a-a few extra questions.
So first, let's actually tackle that question
of why performance matters. Now whenever you're
gonna justify spending time on performance
in your Web applications, there's always a
lot of complex reasons people give why it
matters, why you should do it. To me, and-and
they're all perfectly good, I'm-I'm sure their
great, they include math and return on investment
and everything.
But to me it-it actually comes down to a very
simple thing. Performance affects your users.
I've always said, "Performance is actually
just a characteristic of usability." Now I'm
gonna try to continue to convince you of this,
but I'm only gonna use basically three bullet
points from here on out with some sup, some
supporting evidence, including some demos.
So first bullet point: performance affects
your users simply because it affects your
users' ability to actually use your applications.
So to give you an example of this--get to
the right window here--oh hey, my talk is
starting.
[pause]
So very simple game; you can play along at
your seat. As a matter of fact, I gave you
the URL because it's even harder for me doing
it up here on stage with a track pad, so I'm
probably gonna get some misleading results
as I try it here on stage. Very simple game
-- all you do, you grab the ball, you drop
it in the hole, and it'll time you.
However, as you go through each of these putting
greens, I'm gonna increase the amount of delay.
So the first one obviously zero milliseconds
delay. As you move the mouse as you're dragging
it there's no delay, nothing to interfere
with you. It seems easy. The-the ball stays
right there with the mouse, but if I start
adding additional delay, it-it not only takes
me longer, but it actually feels more difficult.
[pause]
A hundred milliseconds, it's-it's pretty difficult.
Wow.
So the question is, why is that?
So how many people have heard of Fitts's Law?
Probably a number of you. This is usually
the-the sort of HDI concept that tells us
that we want to have big buttons, and we want
to have 'em close. It basically says, "It's
exponentially easier to hit something that's
big and close," which totally makes sense.
Now if you dig a little deeper into Fitts's
Law, it's actually based on something called
the deterministic iterative corrections model,
which is a really fancy way of saying that
the way this works is you need to take your
mouse pointer, and you need to put it over
something. You look at the distance between
where your mouse pointer is and where the
button is, and you tell your hand to go off
in that direction.
Well your hand's not very intelligent on its
own, so at some point you realize there's
some error, and so you correct for that. And
then it, so you change your direction a little
bit, and then you correct again. And you do
this in a series of smaller and smaller sub-movements
until you finally get to your target, right?
In fact, the series of smaller and smaller
sub-movements is where that whole log term
comes from in Fitts's Law.
Now why does this apply to the golf? Well,
if you think about it, applying what I just
described, when you introduce delay what it
means is every time you're do one of those
sub-movements, you're operating on out of
date information. So you have, you can do
two things: you can either slow down, which
obviously is unpleasant, or you can make a
lot more of these small sub-movements.
So net, the sort of the net effect is that
you increase one of the coefficients here
B, which is usually somethin' that varies
from person to person, and it's also something
that tends to get larger as people age. So
the punch line for this whole thing is by
making your apps slow, you actually make your
users feel older. So --
[laughter]
Okay. So the other thing is-is users are just
amazingly sensitive to delays. This is actually
a demo that I showed last year, but I'm gonna
show it again 'cause many people told me it-it
demonstrated sort of the threshold at which
people started to see things. 'Cause it's
often surprising if you do this series where
you start wrapping up delays, the point at
which you actually started to notice.
So let's go over this. Now you've seen this
interaction everywhere. I mean it's all over
the Web. I simply mouse over some links, and
the links highlight to support the fact that
my mouse is now over them. I mean we-we refer
to it as a hover, right?
Now the simple interact that you find everywhere,
what happens if I start adding delay to this?
At what point are you gonna notice? So obviously
at no delay this thing's great; feels good.
If I come up at 25 milliseconds, it's-it's
still keepin' up -- not really a problem.
Maybe if you're eagle eyed in the front row,
you can see something. If I come up to fil-50
milliseconds, I mean it's clearly starting
to lag, but it's not problematic. I mean it
doesn't, it has a little bit of a sluggishness
feel, but if I go all the way up to 100 milliseconds,
I don't care if you were drinking this morning,
or didn't drink this morning, sorry, this
is sluggish. And-and you notice this. This
app actually feels like it's not keeping up
with you; it sort of breaks the metaphor of
your action caused something to happen.
[pause]
Okay.
Now the last one is a surprising one. And
that is that the users' perception of quality
in your application can actually change based
on the performance alone. In fact, there's
a surprising study that shows that not only
can their perception of the quality of your
application change, but actually the content
contained in that application or Webpage can
actually change.
They did, in fact, and here's a link to the
study. They found that, or these researchers
found that as they increased the amount of
latency in loading a Web page, users actually
consistently rated the-the content of those
Web pages lower. I'm obviously, it would very
hard to demo this on stage, so bathroom reading
if you wanna grab the link.
[pause]
But those are fun demos and everything. If
you're gonna remember one thing about, about
sort of the why performance is important and
sort of action items for making your apps
more performant, it's this one number. This
is all you have to remember from this section,
just one single number; it's hundred milliseconds.
So a hundred milliseconds is the amount of
time that you as a developer have to block
the UI event queue in the browser that has
to run code.
So to make it more concrete. If you wire up
a click handler, you have a hundred milliseconds
in that click hander-handler, and you have
to return. You set a timer -- when that timer
fires you got a hundred milliseconds. You
can set another timer -- when it fires you
get another hundred milliseconds. So if you
follow this, then you're-you're apps are going
to feel much snappier.
Hundred milliseconds is not arbitrary. I mean
you saw it appear earlier as I, as I talked
about the delay. Hundred milliseconds is actually
the limit at which humans start, stop seeing
things as being instantaneous. So I say a
hundred milliseconds is the limit, obviously
the average needs to be much lower. If you
make all your events hundred milliseconds,
it's gonna look like that, the hover example
that I showed you.
So keep this number in mind. I'm gonna make
it easier for you because I'm gonna show you
a tool that actually has this number built
right in. But hundred milliseconds really
is the sort of take away from this section.
So we're gonna get into showing Speed Tracer,
but first I wanna continue on this one number:
hundred milliseconds.
Why is it so hard to do things in a hundred
milliseconds? I mean it seems so easy, there's
one-tenth of a second, that's the time I have,
but-but why is that so hard in browsers?
Well the first thing is-is people don't even
measure. I mean this is the, probably the
number reason, and it's a simple fact. And
why would they? It's very hard. I mean if
you think about it, maybe I wanna measure
how much time it takes when I click on a button,
but it's not just enough to measure how much
time it took to do that click amount, I really
wanna know how much time it took when I called
a method from that click handler, and I wanna
know how long that method took, and then I
called another method. So before long I have
this whole framework for taking timings in
my Web app, which is just unwieldy, right?
The second thing is browners-browsers are
all event and call back based. This-this makes
it very hard to know what's causing the problems.
So you may see an animation stutter on application,
you may notice that a, when you click a button
it stayed blue, or, you know, whatever the
depress color is too long, but it's really
hard to know what caused that, because in
addition to handling the click event or running
the animation, you may have a timer going
off, there may be network, there may be data
coming back over the network and an XLMHttpRequest
and your handler ran for that. So it's really
hard to-to cast blame on the one thing that's
causing problems in your application.
And the final thing is browsers are just really
complex. They tend to have lots of nes-nested
sub-systems; they call each other in sort
of mutually recursive ways; extremely hard
to reason about and-and the more tricks that
browser vendors use to make them faster, it
does make it faster, but it also makes it
that much more predictable. So every time
they make something lazy so that it only happens
when you, when you exercise a particular part
of the UI, it becomes much harder to reason
about what's going on.
So we wanted to do somethin' about this 'cause
if-if you've follow along with us for very
long in Google Web Tool Kit, we're all about
writing fast apps. So we said, "Well, we'll
build a tool." And we really wanted a tool
that does two things. It one, it-it tells
you what's goin' on. I said the number one
reason is that no one ever times, well that's,
you really sho-just, should just have a tool
that's timing for you all the time. That tells
you how long it takes to do everything inside
your application.
And when it's timing everything, why not let
it go ahead and tell me what happened inside
the browser? I mean I have to start to understand
what the browser does so that I can make things
faster. If I don't know which sub-system in
the browser is causing me problems, I really
don't know how to structure a fix, right?
So a tool should do, should do these two things.
And this is, this is where Speed Tracer came
from.
So I'm gonna actually spend, now I'm gonna
switch over to the browser, and I'm gonna
spend most of the time showin' you Speed Tracer.
[pause]
So let's start with an application you're,
you're probably familiar with, hopefully:
Google Calendar. You can see I have an extremely
busy schedule this week. And we're just gonna
use this as an example application. I'm gonna
show you Speed Tracer monitoring the performance
in Calendar. Now Calendar's it's-it's a, it's
a fast application. The engineers on Calendar
have honed it, they've tweaked it, they've
used tools like Speed Tracer, and they've
made it fast.
But we're gonna use it to-to sort of show
things off.
So I open Speed Tracer. Speed Tracer's a Chrome
extension. And you'll see that I just, to
get it started, I just clicked on this button
up here in the, in the top of the browser
Chrome.
Okay, so I'm gonna go back to Calendar here,
and I'm just gonna reload it so that we have
somethin' to look at, and then I can describe
what we're seein'. Go back into Speed Tracer.
As you probably expect going left to right
is time -- very common way to represent time.
I'm, I'm gonna zoom out so that we can get
a better view, and then sort of working from
top to bottom, there's obviously a control
bar at the top which gives you things like
zooming. You saw me just zoom all the way
out so that I can see all the data.
Next is, and probably the most noticeable
thing is this graph called the Sluggishness
graph. Now this sort encapsulates that hundred
milliseconds that I told you about earlier.
The Sluggishness graph is intended to be really
simple to use. That is if your, if your application
causes the Sluggishness graph to hit 100 percent
at the top of the graph, then you're keeping
the browser too busy, which basically means
that you ran something longer than a hundred
milliseconds. And we even have little heuristics
so that if you continually run things that
are even some fraction of a hundred milliseconds,
you continue to sort of push up the Sluggishness
graph.
The intent here is that you can very easily
run it on the application, and it tells you
when things are bad. Rather than giving you
a whole dump of data and then you go and analyze
it, you try to figure out where the slow part
is, this actually tells you when it thinks
something is not performing well.
Obviously if you keep, if you keep the graph
low, well below a hundred milliseconds, everything's,
everything's wonderful.
So typically the way you use this is you start,
you look at your application and you, and
you sort of watch the Sluggishness graph looking
for these peaks. And they, they shine or stand
out on the overview graph down below, which
shows you the full timeline. Once you find
somethin' of interest, then this is about
the only data we have from Calendar right
here in this region, I can simply select directly
on the Sluggishness graph and zoom in.
Now zooming in, zooming in we get the full
details of everything that happens. We list
all the browser events that happened; the
top level events, so this can include everything
from parsing HTML as you load up the, the
main HTML page; it can be timer aspiring;
it even shows paints for the when the browser
decided to repaint the screen.
Then if you dig deeper into those and expand
one, you can see that you get the full details
of everything that happened during the, during
this event. And like I said, browser sub-systems
tend to be very mutually recursive so you
see things like a layout being called recursively
and parsing of HTML often causes scripts to
run; these sort of things that are very hard
to reason about. You sort of have them, you
can see them laid out in this convenient event
trace.
Now if I then click on, if I then click on
one of the nodes on the tree, I can get even
more details about exactly what happened;
the details are specific to that type of event,
so they often help you particularly when one
of these are very large, to find out exactly
what's causin' the problem.
And I'm goin' show you sort of a working example
of that soon.
Okay, so one of the things I wanna highlight
is that a, is that many tools focus on sort
of the loading of your application when it
first loads off your Web server, and it's
sort of getting started fast, but that's really
only a part of the story.
What you really want when you're building
interactive applications, is you want somethin'
they continue to watch because it's not just
the loading of your application, it has to
continue to feel, continue to not be sluggish
as we termed it here.
So to-to just give you a sense of that real
quick: if I go back in the Calendar and I
suspect that I'll probably wanna go for drinks
later for awhile--
[laughter]
Let's call that "Drinks." Go back to Speed
Tracer. Now I'm gonna use the zoom button
again so I can see the whole timeline, and
I can find that new data that came in. The
zoom out I see that I have some new data over
to the right here; gonna zoom into that. And-and
basically the point is here you-you saw that
just as I got the data, as the application
was loaded, I can continue to get the data
'cause this is, Calendar is an AJAX-style
application, so that it continues to run code
and update, and it's very interactive. So
I can continue to monitor that application
as I use it, not just when I'm loading the
page.
Okay, so I'm gonna jump back, zoom out real
quick, and jump back in to talk about the
next part.
You've probably noticed a few of these top
level events have little green, green, orange,
and sometimes red indicators to the side.
We call these hints. The-the idea here was
that we do a lot of performance investigations
with Speed Tracer, and we often discover patterns.
One-one I'm gonna show you in the next section.
And it's nice to go ahead and-and sort of
encapsulate, or identify these patterns and
then build some rules to just point them out
for you.
Some of them, some of them are very simple.
So in this case, this is simply an event that
took just slightly over a hundred milliseconds.
But since it took over, took over a hundred
milliseconds, I wanna sort of give you a light
warning that says, "Hey, this kinda took a
long time; it's a green, it's a green hint
so it's not really critical, but it's something
you should know about." It if took even longer,
the thing would get more critical.
And we have a, we have a number of hints that
have to do with the run time of your application
and also on the network panel, which shows
you all the network resources that they loaded
over the network. It also shows you best practices
here for instance, caching of resources; and
so recommending that you, that you increase,
use the right headers for your cache policies
for your resources so you don't always have
to fetch them from the server.
You also notice that now that I'm talkin'
about the network view, it's, it may be hard
to see, but the network view is actually sort
underlaid on the Sluggishness view, so you
can kind of see them both at the same time.
The reason why we did this is because you
always have these HTMLHttpRequests which are
goin' off to the server, they're getting data,
they're bringing 'em back, and you always
run code as a result. If you used Google Web
Tool Kit when you do an RPC, you see this
happen. You go and you do something on the
server and then something, the request comes
back and you run some code and it's actually
very handy to, handy to know exactly when
the data came back from the network and then
something ran in the browser. So we wanna
correlate things going on in the network with
things that are happening inside the browser
or inside your code.
Okay, so the final thing I wanna show you
as part of sort of the run through of Speed
Tracer, is say, say we've used Speed Tracer,
we've found, used it on our application, we've
just found a performance problem. Now, it's
really hard to talk about performance problems.
I can, I can send an email to my teammate,
and I can say, "Yeah, when you push this button,
and then you do this and you resize this,
it gets really slow and it seems like this
is not updating." And even if I had to communicate
all the data in Speed Tracer, it would be
really hard, right? I'd have to say, "Well,
it's 32.4 percent layout, and it's 15 percent
recalculation." It's just not an efficient
way to talk about these problems.
What I would rather do, is I would rather
take what I have here, send it to my teammate
or-or post it on mar-in our issue tracker
system, and then have that person open it
back up and look at what I was seeing. So
to, so when we did Speed Tracer, we added
the save/load functionality, so I just hit,
hit save, and I save this just as I would
a Web page; save that to my Desktop. I send
that to my teammate, and I say, "Hey could
you take a look at this? I don't really like
the way this thing is performing." And let
me switch back.
[pause]
So, I then open up that file I just received
by email; I click open monitor; and we're
right back to where we were. So, so my teammate
can see exactly what I saw when I found the
problem. So it's much easier to talk about
performance problems when you do run into
them.
[pause]
Close those out.
All right.
[pause]
Okay. So that's sort of the full, that's sort
of the full tour of the Speed Tracer UI. That
gives you a sense of-of how to use it at the
high level.
But now I wanna dive a little deeper and take
a couple of specific examples a-a scenarios
where we've had to do a performance investigations
on internal Google applications and some external
applications.
Now I've simplified these examples 'cause
I, if I didn't we would spend three hours
just going, trying to explain to you the code
of some of these applications. But, hopefully,
it'll give you a flavor of the types of things
you can find, and the ways in which Speed
Tracer pinpoints the problem.
So we're gonna start with a, an example I
like to call the "The mysterious case of too
much layout." And this is one of my favorites
to show because this is absolutely something
we did not know about until we started looking
at these applications in a Speed Tracer.
I'll tell you that we originally ran into
this problem, we're helping the AdWords Front
End Team. Now as you can imagine, that team
needs to display a lot of tables. They need
to display tables with numbers in them and
you, in fact, many of them for probably obvious
reasons you want to edit it; you want to edit
the-the values. I don't think they're as powerful
as this, you can't actually change the melting
point of hydrogen, but you get the point.
So very simple; I-I've brought it down to
this simple part. I wanna build a table; I
want that table to be editable. So and I'm
gonna, let me close this window just so I
don't get confused. So I'm gonna go ahead
and open Speed Tracer as I talk. Make that
a full screen and return here.
Now I'm gonna clear this for a second, and
I'm gonna show you what we originally saw
in their UI, and the thing that had them distressed.
So they had to build up this table, so when
they did that they hit run and you notice
that that button stayed blue for a little
long, and it was actually a little bit of
delay there as it built up the table. This
table, and if you style it even more, the
performance gets worse.
So let's, let's actually look at it in Speed
Tracer and confirm that it was probably a
little longer than we wanted. In fact, it's
about 431 milliseconds which, that's-that's
well beyond the hundred milliseconds that
we're aimin' for.
So now being engineers, and I am as guilty
as probably anyone, I knew what the problem
was. There was no need to even look at it
in a tool, I mean we all knew what the problem
was. We were sure of ourselves, and so let
me show you what the code looked like to begin
with.
Very simple. This is just a part of it, right?
When we built a cell for each one of these
tables, we-we created a cell which just a-a-a
TD Element in HTML speak; then we created
a span to put our text in. We needed the,
we needed the width of the, of the cell because
we wanted to have this hidden text box, right?
So we wanted to put this there. We just wanted
it to be there so we could just, made it easy,
we would just enable it and show it whenever
someone clicked on the cell. And then of course
we wired up the click handlers to show it,
and when-when you leave the text box we committed
our changes; those, really simple.
But I was sure that the problem was, I mean
you hear all the time it takes a long time
to build up DOM Elements, right. And here
we are we're buildin' too many DOM Elements.
So I built a hidden text box that I didn't
even need.
No need to even look at it in the tool. We
know what the problem was, let's just go ahead
and fix it. So we fix the code and by comparison
you'll see that all I did is I moved this
text box inside the click event, right? So
this-this should fix our problem. It was,
it was wonderful it only took a few minutes
to fix it. And, but surprisingly when we tried
it, it didn't seem much faster. And looking
at it in Speed Tracer--
[pause]
sort of confirm. It did get a little faster,
but certainly not below a hundred milliseconds,
which we were aimin' for. Now, I was suddenly
a lot less certain about what the problem
was. So now let's-let's actually do the right
thing, and let's go back and look, let's go
back and look at the original event in Speed
Tracer, and see what it actually says the
problem is.
So I'm gonna zoom out again and find that
original event. We see the hump over here
to, on the left of the graph. I'm gonna zoom
into that hump, and this time let's expand
it. Okay, well first of all I'm looking at
the breakdown and it's clear that the problem
here is, we're doing too much layout.
And if I were not convinced by that, if I
scroll down through what actually happened,
there is no doubt that the problem is that
I'm doing way too much layout. But, but that's
interesting to know, but what do I do about
that? I don't even know I caused the layout
problem, right? I mean I wouldn't even know
how to fix that.
Okay, well, let's-let's click on one and find
out. I thought the problem was the-the input
box. If I then click on, well that's certainly
not the line that I thought was the problem,
right? So, okay, well maybe that one was just
a fluke; maybe it's being caused by a variety
of things. If I click on other of these, no,
the, the panel is unanimous. It looks like
the problem is not what I thought it was,
which was that it was taking me too long to
build up all my UI. The problem is that I
was somehow forced in the browser to do a
bunch of layout, and so I'll explain in detail
why what's happening here, but before I do
that, let's actually fix the problem.
So, so here's where we were on the last step;
I had moved everything inside my click handler
so I could build up my, part of my UI lazily.
I-I'm just gonna move one line this time.
I'm just gonna move that width inside the
click handler instead and go ahead and move
it in with the building of the input element.
Let's clear it and see what that does. Well,
you can already tell it was a lot faster,
right? But if I switch back over to Speed
Tracer to confirm it and see how much faster
it is, well, it's-it's actually kinda hard
to find because it's, because it's small and
let's see here it is down here: 12 milliseconds;
sure beats the heck out of 400 milliseconds.
It does exactly the same thing, right? And
this is something that could have puzzled
me for days had I not been guided by a tool
to sort of show that there was a problem and
where the problem was.
In fact, you'll notice that the strange thing
is, after I went and changed this code, no
layout actually occurs in this event. In fact,
the layout occurs after the fact; after this
event is completely finished, the browser
does layout. Now that may seem strange to
you, so let me show you a quick example, that-that
illustrates what's goin' on here.
I-I told you before that browser vendors are
always trying to make things lazy. So they're
trying to make things lazy because it's-it's
a little bit of an issue with the APIs inside
the browser. At any point you can ask for
the width of something, and you may actually
change that width as you go, or you may change
the styles. And what they try to do is they
try not to lay everything out for you every
time you change somethin' because that would
be silly. If they, if you happen to be changing
five class names in a row, then they don't
want to update all the layout every time you
change something so they try to be sneaky.
They try to wait until you read something
that needs the layout information before they
do the layout.
But that can actually, that can actually get
you in trouble because if you're, if you're
constantly reading things that happen, that
cause layout, at the same time that you're
setting things that invalidate that layout
information, you start causing this pattern
that we've been referring to as "layout thrashing."
Sort of a simple example here that I hope
illustrates it, right? Two lines, you're setting
a class name and you're taking the width.
Now the top one is, the top one is going to
be a lot, a lot slower than the bottom one
simply because I forced some layout, which
I then immediately just threw away. I may
not have even needed that-that width at the
same time. And that's a, and browsers try
to be smart about certain sub-trees of the
DOM and invalidating only parts of the tree,
but because of some of the, because of some
of the ways the DOM tree works, it's actually,
it's actually quite hard, and it could be
surprising invalidating something on one part
of the DOM can actually have ripple effects
in other parts of the UI.
So this was a very surprising result to us.
We've run into it time and time again, and
it is actually a hint lid inside of Speed
Tracer, and you probably saw that when we
looked at that, when I expanded the-the tree
for that first one, you saw that it was offerin'
a hintlet to tell you that you had a lot of
layout activity, and it very much looked like
one of these cases where you were thrashing
in the layout.
Okay, so let's switch to our next example
here, which I call "the mysterious case of
too much data." Now there's no one app I can
blame this one on. This actually has happened
quite a bit. It's a, it's an age-old question
when you're doing Web applications which have
talk to a server it sort of classic client
server model. Figuring out what to send from
the server when, right? I don't, I cannot,
obviously I can't get my app up fast and load
my entire database into the client side, and
I also don't want to fetch every little piece
of data every time it's needed, so there's
a nice balancing act from getting the right
amount of data to the front-end at just the
right time.
So, and for this example I actually reused,
I actually reused just some an, a piece of
code I had layin' around. The reason I had
it layin' around is because it's the way I
explain that why I moved from Boston to Atlanta.
So you'll notice when I hit load everything,
and all this thing did is was it fetched all
the weather stations in the U.S., and it just
sort of plotted 'em on a canvas, right. So
we're seein' all the weather stations in the
U.S. Unsurprisingly it kinda looks familiar
when you just sort of draw 'em on a canvas,
right?
But the reason why I like this app is because
it shows why I moved from Boston. You notice
the low ends of the graph here? And went to-
[pause]
Atlanta. Oooh, notice the nice ends of the
graph that correspond with the winters. Those
are actually the temperatures for the year
2009 -- so, much warmer in Atlanta.
But to show you again, and I'm gonna open
Speed Tracer this time so we can get a sense
of how long things actually take. I'm gonna
hit the, I'm gonna clear this, and I'm gonna
hit load everything again. And this is loading
everything as it says. I'm loading not only
positions for all the weather stations, but
I'm also loading all that data for 2009. Now
I feel justified in doing this because I'm
over a fast connection, and it's probably
gonna get cached, and this is sort of a limited
purpose application anyway; I'm mostly just
showin' it to in presentations like this.
And so in fact if I go to the network, and
I look at how long it took to fetch over the
network, it was actually pretty fast. I mean
it didn't take that long. It was, total it
was less than a second to fetch the data.
Now the surprising thing, is that while it
was less than a second to fetch the data,
actually parsing the data because it was JSONed
was half a second, right? So even if it was
cached, I still have to sustain a half a second
of the UI being locked up, right? And this
is just simple JSON structure. I mean it's
like a-a list of objects that contain lists,
right? It's not-not really that complex.
So the other thing I wanna use with this example,
is I wanna demonstrate a feature of Speed
Tracer. Now if I expand this, you'll notice
that Speed Tracer's shamefully not doing very
well here. It's just tellin' me I ran a bunch
of JavaScript. It's saying you ran a bunch
of JavaScript, and it took a long time.
Well, that's not really helpful for a developer,
right. I mean, I-I really need what I had
on the last example, which is for Speed Tracer
to point out a particular line for me to fix.
We're currently workin' on that. We're gonna
continue to add instrumentation and hopefully
get there, but in the meantime you need a
way out if you get stuck.
So I want to show you your way out. Let me
clear this and show you a piece of code.
Now you can imagine when the data comes back
over the network, this does a couple of things.
It parses the JSON and then it renders. Now
a, this is another one where I fooled myself,
and I said, "Clearly the problem is that it's
taking a long time to draw this stuff to canvas"
and then it's not the case and I've already
sort of tipped this off. But-but the main
thing I wanna point out is I've added some
lines here; I've done console at mark timeline,
and I've passed a string.
Now this, this is basically a way to put additional
information into Speed Tracer's tree. So every
time I do this console at mark timeline, I'm
basically tellin' Speed Tracer, "Okay, take
this string and wherever it happened in the
timing, just embed that string." So I can
find these points in the tree, right?
So let me show that, show you that. And I'm
gonna enable the logging, and we're gonna
load everything again. I go back to Speed
Tracer; zoom all the way out so I can see
the-the new data all the way over here on
the right; and again zoom in; and again 448
milliseconds; pretty long. But you'll notice
this time instead of just being a big blob
of JavaScript, I also have these logs in here
which correspond directly to the strings that
I-I put in, that you saw in the code.
And in fact, you'll also notice that there
is a little blue icon over here on the event
itself, so you can actually use this mark
timeline to actually find, particularly if
you have a-a app that uses a lot of timers.
It's often very hard to actually find the
event you're lookin' for. Console at mark
timeline is a great way to actually find what
you're lookin' for.
And so you see the, you see the strings here
that I had in the code. Now a trick that not
many people know about is if I wanna know
the difference be, in time from any two nodes
in the tree, I can use a little hidden feature
which is on Windows, I do control click, on
Mac, I do command click, and it will tell
me the time difference between these two nodes.
So it's pretty clear that the problem now
is parsing JSON, not the rendering. Parsing
JSON was about 306, 360 milliseconds. This
was doing the rendering only about 45 milliseconds.
And it's also not surprising with all that
information that the fix for this was simply
to just not load everything. So rather than
loading all the data for 2009 for all the
stations up front, I just wait and load that
weather data on demand.
So let's try the other strategy here: the
load as needed. It'll-it came up a lot faster
which you probably already noticed, and of
course it works just the same. But let's go
back and confirm what we saw--whoops--inside
of Speed Tracer. Again, I'll actually use
a, since I keep zooming out let me just move
over here this time.
And, yeah, 50, 56 milliseconds this time;
a lot better. Parsing the JSON just by dropping
those, those arrays from each of the different
elements, it goes down a whole 28 milliseconds.
So, much, much better.
So-so those are two example that I hope show
you sort of, they're sort of scenarios ha-that
show you how you can use Speed Tracer to-to
conquer real world stuff, not just sort of
takin' you on a tour of the UI, actually shows
you simplified playbacks of what we've done
in our own performance investigations.
So now, let me get back to my slides.
I wanna talk about new features.
I'm gonna show you three new features. Two
of 'em are in what we're callin' our milestone,
which is, if you're going now in your seat
and you're downloading Speed Tracer, or you
already have it installed, and you just noticed
a new version arrived, that is the milestone.
So up or download right now is the milestone
that will have two of these features in it.
The third one, we're still experiment-experimenting
with, but it'll be available soon. And of
course we're open source so if you're really
interested you can grab it now out of the
source repository.
So the first thing and I-I've, I gave this
away early. The number one requested feature
was that people said, "Can you please show
me the line of code that's causin' the problem?"
Now obviously when I did the case of too much
layout, I already showed you this, right.
We jumped right to the line of code.
So I'm not gonna show you that again. Instead
I'm gonna say we took it a little bit, we
took it a little bit further in some cases.
So, for people who are doing GWT code, they
write in Java, right? And in fact when you
jump to that line of JavaScript code, it's
not pretty. I mean it, it's really hard to
make sense of it.
We-we actually wanna jump back to the line
of Java code. So people laughed and they said,
"Yeah, yeah, yeah, take us back to the line
of Java code," and we weren't quite sure how
to do that, and so we kinda laughed along
with them. But we-we finally figured somethin'
out, and let-let me show you what we figured
out.
So I'm gonna, this is an application, if you
use App Engine, the Java SDK App Engine, you're
probably familiar with this particular application.
It's actually one of the samples.
And, and I-I am, I'm gonna use Speed Tracer
on it, but the way I launched this one was
instead of just sort of going to the application,
going to the application and then bringing
Speed Tracer up on it, I actually used a new
feature that's part of the Google Eclipse,
Google Plug-in, Google Eclipse Plug-in, or
Google Plug-in for Eclipse, I'm sorry.
So you'll notice in their new version that
there is now a new menu item that I can save
profile as Speed Tracer. Okay, I've already
run this 'cause I didn't, obviously since
you wanna run in production mode it runs to
the GWT Compiler. I didn't want you guys to
wait on that on stage. So I already have it
running for us over here.
I'm gonna open Speed Tracer; make it full
screen; return back here. I'm simply gonna
refresh this guy, just so we can get some
data. Now I hear Sticky was written by somebody
who has just mad front-end skills so it's
really fast. I wrote it.
[laughter]
And I'm gonna zoom in on the-the little bit
of data we have and I'm gonna focus in on
this XMLHttpRequest 'cause that looks like
some interesting data, and now I look and
there's some parsed HTML and I'm gonna, again
I wanna look at the line of code that caused
this and-and if I wanna look at the JavaScript
then I can look at the JavaScript, and it's
about as intelligible as I thought it was
gonna be. It's highly obfuscated, but you
also notice there's something new for this
particular trace. Right underneath the line
of code for JavaScript is, hopefully you can
read that, is a Java identifier. If you're,
if you've written Google Web Tool Kit front-end
code, you recognize this Google, com.googlegwtuserclientuimage.
You-you're probably familiar with this.
And if I click on this link, then I actually
go right into Eclipse. So-
[applause]
So-so hopefully that helped. I-I know that
many people have, have not enjoyed looking
at the obfuscated JavaScript. We thought that
jumping directly into the ID would probably
be suitable for people who are really attached
to their tools like Eclipse, as we are.
Okay. So the next feature which you probably
saw if you, if you stayed for the whole keynote,
is Server Side Profile Tracing. So I had a
lot of people who-who they said, "Well I've,
I've-I've worked on my front-end code, and
it's really fast, but I still have this slow
section, and it's the server so the server
guy hopefully will eventually take care of
it, but I don't know what's goin' on." And
they said, "It would be really cool if Speed
Tracer could just tell me what was goin' on
in the server, could show me the traces for
what happened on the server." We thought that
was a great idea as well, and so I'm gonna
show you this particular example on App Engine.
So we've taken Sticky, the sample app, and
we've deployed it to App Engine. And I've
turned on App Stats, which is a new feature
inside of App Engine that-that tells you what
happens inside of App En-inside of App Engine
as you run your application, much as the way
Speed Tracer shows you what happens inside
the browser when you run your, the front-end
part of your application.
Now I'm gonna open Speed Tracer.
[pause]
And let's go back here and do something. Maybe-
type somethin' in here, maybe move something
around. All of these are causing writes back
to the App Engine. So it's telling the datastore
to save the position of the Sticky and to
update the content.
I'm gonna go back to Speed Tracer, and I'm
going to zoom all the way out and go to the
Network Panel. You-you'll notice that some
of these, or in fact all of these, now have
a special icon beside them that indicates
that, in addition to knowing how long things
took in HttpRequest headers that are in there,
it also has additional information about what
happened on the server, and if I click on
one of these, it'll actually fill in with
a trace that came directly from App Engine.
And if you've used App Engine you recognize
these names. This is a get from the data store.
We began a transaction, did another get, did
a put, committed the results and then deleted
somethin' from memcache and in fact that's
when I updated something so it, it ended up
invalidating my, invalidating my cache so
the next time, or invalidating my memcache,
so the next time I actually had to do a bunch
of queries to get everything instead of just
pulling it out of memcache.
So we think this is really cool, to be able
to see the full story from the client side
all the way back into the server, and just
really get a sense for what is taking a long
time, regardless of whether it's the browser
or the back-end serve, the back-end serving
infrastructure.
And the other thing about this is it's available
in two exciting flavors. For App Engine, which
I just showed you, is based on App Stats.
There is actually a talk, sadly it's going
on right now, but there's a talk here at Google
I/O about App Stats if you're interested in
that part.
And-and the other is, as part of our work
with SpringSource if you're a user of their
tc Server Developer Edition, they have a tool
called Spring Insight which shou-which has
similar statistics for their, for their stack
and Speed Tracer works there as well. So you
can get these, if you're, if you're usin'
that container as well you can get these traces
right up in Speed Tracer.
Okay, so those are the two things that are
contained in the milestone that you can download
right now.
The next thing, the next thing is, we're still
workin' on, but we're actually quite excited
about.
Now you often work very hard to get your performance
down. You spend about two weeks or so, and
you're trying to get the performance in your
Web application just as tight as possible,
and then you get it fast, and you celebrate,
and you go out for beers, and then at some
unspecified time later, you realize that it's
no longer fast again because somebody committed
something.
Somebody didn't know about the excessive layout
thing, they weren't looking at it with Speed
Tracer all the time, they committed something,
and all that work you've done is now out the
window and not only that you're stuck with
a window of some number of revisions that
you now have to do a binary search on to figure
out exactly what broke it.
So we, teams kept telling us, "I really just
wish, I work really hard to remove the, a
lot of the layout out of the start of my application.
I wish every time somebody put something in
that it automatically ran Speed Tracer on
it and can tell me if the layout went up again."
So we thought that was a pretty good idea
as well, and so we were like, "Well, okay
what do we need? What do we actually need?
Well really all we need is headless Speed
Tracer, watches your application while it
runs in your continuous build, and then sends
the-those results somewhere for analysis."
So we built the headless Speed Tracer, and
now what we're doin' is we're testing it on
some, some internal applications, and we're
trying to figure the right formula for a dashboard.
I'll give you sort of an inside peek on where
we are with the dashboard. This is actually
an internal application we've been monitoring,
and we're tryin' to see if we can, we can
actually see the regressions as they happen.
And so we're, we're doing this; we're running
their, we have Speed Tracer in a continuous
build for them. It just sends all its data
back to our dashboard; we do some analysis
over it; and we just plot everything. And
so we're-we're monitor it on an on-going basis
to watch things change, to see how things
change.
We're monitoring a lot of different things
at this point. One is the breakdown of what
happened. I mentioned earlier we-we've actually
done a lot of exercises. We've just helped
teams to remove layout; this excessive layout
from certain parts of their applications,
and they want to keep it out. They want it
to stay fast; they don't want people accidentally
checking something in that-that-that breaks
all their hard work. So we sort of monitor
the breakdown if, if we notice that the layout
goes up then obviously it, we should probably
investigate that change list that went in
that-that caused that to happen.
Monitoring other things, like I don't how
many people are familiar with GWT's lightweight
metrics. There's actually a system built into
it that tells you how long it took a module
to load; we're monitoring this, that for the
application as well. And-and a lot of other
things.
But-but the main thing is, is that this will
enable you to-to put Speed Tracer in your
continuous build and start to actually analyze
what's going on in your application as it
runs as part of the build, which we think
is, is going to be pretty important.
Okay.
So the next thing I'll tell you is go grab
a copy of the milestone. It's-it's available
at this link. I'm sure the link is going to
be in the, in the Wave. We actually have some
Googlers taking notes; so important facts
like this will be in there.
And I'm happy to take a few questions. While-while
I take questions I'm gonna leave this slide
up. This is my contact information -- some
additional Speed Tracer URL's. Speed Tracer
is a open source project and that bottom link
is actually directly to the open source, source
repository at Google Code.
And finally a reminder that we're gonna be
takin' notes inside of Google Wave.
Now I'm gonna, I-I'm going to just do live
questions during this part, but if you've
put a question in Moderator I'm just gonna
answer it throughout the day so we can continue
to talk there. I hope that's okay, but I decided
to, to just field the questions for the people
in the room, while people are in the room,
that way I can actually answer more questions
than I could if I tried to handle Moderator
while on stage, so.
Thank you, guys, and I'm happy to field questions
now.
[applause]
Oh, and please use the mic. Please use the
mic for questions so that we're gonna actually
be recording, so I wanna make sure that your
question is on, is on the audio.
>>male in audience: I have a question about
the example you have with Java going back
to Java line,
>>Kelly Norton: Uh-hum.
>>male in audience: but what can you do at
that point because I think there's another
abstraction with-with Java, how do you know
how it translates into JavaScript? Maybe that's
hidden from you. Do you -
>>Kelly Norton: Yeah.
>>male in audience: have to do, do you have
to write Jav-JavaScript and then interface
it with GWT?
>>Kelly Norton: Right. So, so it's a good
question and actually I've found there's a
big, one of the other advantages that I didn't
even mention of this is, you saw that I clicked
on the link first that brought up the JavaScript,
and then I clicked on the link that brought
up the Java. Now it turns out that that's
actually really powerful in itself because
you often want to ask the question, "What
did the GWT compiler do for me?"
And it just turns out to be a really convenient
way to answer that question because you can
actually bring up the JavaScript inside a
Speed Tracer and bring it up in an IDE and
obviously on your work station you typically
have more than the 10/24 by 7/68 that I have
here. So you can bring 'em up side by side,
and it actually helps to answer that question
in an efficient manner because otherwise you
would have to look at the Java code, and then
you would have to open the JavaScript code
in an editor, and then you would have to find
the function that you're lookin' for. Well
this-this allows much quicker way to compare
them side by side. So we often, we actually
often use that quite a bit to-to figure out
exactly what the GWT compiler is doing.
>>male in audience: [inaudible]
>>Kelly Norton: Sorry. Okay.
>>male in audience: Hi. Thanks for your talk.
>>Kelly Norton: Thank you.
>>male in audience: I have a question about
the server tracing feature 'cause you said
it was compatible with App Engine and SpringSource.
Is there any documentation on the kind of
data you need to get back from the server
to be able to display it in Speed Tracer?
>>Kelly Norton: There is, there is not currently
anything besides our source repository but
there is about to be. It-it's actually pretty
simple. It turns out that the event trace
that we show for the, for what's goin' on
inside the browser, is exactly the sort of
nested data structure you want for the server.
The only thing that sort of confounds it is
if you're using multiple threads, and we haven't
really handled that case quite yet, but it's,
you basically just end of creating a JSON
structure that has this, this, this sort of
tree appearance. It's, we're gonna, at some
point after I/O we're actually gonna get the
data at least published to the open source
group while we continue to tweak on it, but,
but yeah, it's pretty simple JSON format.
>>male in audience: Okay, thanks.
>>Kelly Norton: Look for that to show up soon.
>>male in audience: It's actually the same
question-
>>Kelly Norton: Oh, cool.
>>male in audience: I had.
>>Kelly Norton: Awesome.
And, and also if you, if you have server-side
tools that you wanna make this work with,
feel free to, to, we have there's Speed Tracer
Dev Google Group. Feel free to email that
group, and we'll, we'll help you get to where
you need to be. So-
>>male in audience: Right. So, thank you for
the talk. I'm not sure if this falls into
the realm of Speed Tracer, but it's about
profiling. What happens is, most of the developers
are running Speed Tracer on a faster machines
than your end user would and is there any
direction that you can create profiles and
do caps on CPU or memory and get a more realistic
profile rather than a little skewed from a
developers point of view?
>>Kelly Norton: Yeah, that's, it's a great
idea. We're interested in it. We haven't really
done, we haven't really done much in that,
in that realm. But I think it's an absolutely
great idea. For instance, particularly if
you could use, if you could use things we
know about, the breakdown of users and their
machines, that would be even better. And to
say things like, "Oh, well this event ran
fine for you, but on this particular demographic
it's not gonna run well."
I mean there are a lot of great ideas, on
that obviously we haven't done anything yet,
but I think something like that would be really
cool.
>>male in audience: Thank you.
[pause]
>>male in audience: I was just wanted to ask
about the developer plug-in for Chrome.
>>Kelly Norton: Yep.
>>male in audience: For Mac OS. Do you know
of any news on that?
>>Kelly Norton: The-the developer -
>>male in audience: So you can run the code
server and then run Chrome and MAC OS and
use Speed Tracer against that. I don't know
I may have just-
>>Kelly Norton: Oh, you mean for Chrome OS
or for?
>>male in audience: Yeah. Oh, no. Sorry for
Mac OS.
>>Kelly Norton: Oh, Mac OS-
>>Male in audience: Yeah.
>>Kelly Norton: for Mac OS on Chrome or?
>>male in audience: Yeah.
>>Kelly Norton: Um.
>>male in audience: Like with developer plug-ins
so you can-
>>voice in audience: [inaudible]
>>Kelly Norton: Oh, oh, oh, you mean the,
the-the, when you're actually running inside
of development mode.
>>male in audience: Yeah.
>>Kelly Norton: [ ]. Okay.
So yes. The, we still don't have a plug-in
for Mac as you've pointed out, for Mac Chrome,
right?
>>male in audience: Yeah.
>>Kelly Norton: I-I don't know when that's
coming. Bruce do you know? Is Bruce still
in the room? Does it-
I don't know. If you email me, I can find
out. I-I-I got kind of detached from what's
gonna on with development mode, but, but I
can find out for ya. I think it's, there's
been a lot of discussion about it, I'm just
not sure when it's gonna come, when it's gonna
come about.
Doing Speed Chaser in development mode obviously
gives you a lot of misleading results, but,
but yeah, development mode for Chrome on the
Mac is desperately needed -- Linux as well.
[pause]
>>male in audience: Hi. Thank you for your
talk. I was curious about your last feature
if anyone-if you know of anyone developing
a Hudson Plugin for-for that?
>>Kelly Norton: You mean the headless?
>>male in audience: Yeah.
>>Kelly Norton: Yeah. So the only place that-that
exists right now is in, in the source control
repository for Speed Tracer. So if you're
interested feel free to grab it, compile it,
try it out yourself. We're open source project
so if you wanna contribute back, it's awesome.
What's we're really tryin' to do with that
right now is we know that, we know that we
want this thing in the continuous build, but
it's actually so much data to analyze, we're
tryin' to figure out exactly the sort of things
that we're gonna wanna look on-look at on
an on-going basis, so we're still tryin' to
sort of simplify the reams of data.
So to-so if there's anybody who wants to help
out and wants to sort of try it out, the more
da-the more data we can get about what sort
of things people want to see, the easier it
will be to-to get to something more, faster
that-that is actually simple enough to-to
use on-on a daily basis in your continuous
build. So-
>>male in audience: Thanks.
>>male in audience: Thanks the GWT Speed Tracer.
It's frickin' awesome.
But we've done a mock timeline in the console.
Is there anything in GWT or that would just
be a native method that you'd just passing
in a string to at the present?
>>Kelly Norton: Right now it's just you create
a-a JS9 method-
>>male in audience: Yep.
>>Kelly Norton: and call it directly.
>>Kelly Norton: There's actually some talk
about doing something a little, a little more
clever. In fact we've, I'm-I'm-I made a pitch
to add a console at mark timeline into all
the widgets that you could turn on in a permutation
so that you get like full traces of when things
happen.
>>male in audience: Yep.
>>Kelly Norton: So something like that's gonna
happen soon, but right now just call it as
a native method, yeah.
>>male in audience: Excellent, thank you.
>>Kelly Norton: Sure.
>>male in audience: So first of all, thank
you for that connection to the Java code.
That was by far my biggest phony request,
like I scrolled out half of my complaints
as soon as you-
>>Kelly Norton: Awesome.
>>male in audience: got to that point.
>>Kelly Norton: That's cool.
>>male in audience: Maybe a couple more kind
of phony requests here. So knowing the line
of code that caused the problem is nice, but
if-if you profile like in an all Java stack,
use a profiler, generally you record, and
then you stop recording-
>>Kelly Norton: Yep.
>>male in audience: and you kind of get times
per method. And Speed Tracer doesn't work
that way I'd assume because maybe browsers
don't really work that way.
>>Kelly Norton: Yep.
>>male in audience: It's like call backs and
stuff, but it's kind of hard to correlate
like that this code took a lot of time, as
opposed to oh this is just the entry to the
code that maybe took a lot of time. Is there
a way that Speed Tracer can sort of help us
find those hot spots?
>>Kelly Norton: Yes. Stay tuned. We're-we're
actually, Eric who's duckin' his head out
there in the audience, raise your head Eric,
raise your hand Eric. So Eric is actually
workin' some, some integration with a, with
a conventional JavaScript debugger which,
there's still, there's still a lot of technical
work to be done for that. Of course everything
we do we sort of work with Chrome and Web
Kit teams to-to figure out the best way to
do it.
So, we-we're actually doing that right now
with integration with the profiler. The-the
thought is that what we would do is-is in
addition to having that sort of event stream-
>>male in audience: Um-hum.
>>Kelly Norton: you could click on any event
and actually get a profile for that particular
event. Right-
>>male in audience: [unintelligible]
>>Kelly Norton: so it's actually still organized
in the way that Speed Tracer likes to organize
things, but you-you get all the information
that you would have in a, in a regular JavaScript
profiler. So-
>>male in audience: And then one maybe tiny
pony request and maybe just your expertise.
Sometimes I'm afraid that we lose a lot of
time, we deliver big payloads, JSON payloads,
and we Gzip them because we wanna adhere to
best practices and try to make it as small
as possible, and sometimes I'm afraid that
the browser's taking a long time to unGzip
them-
>>Kelly Norton: Right.
>>male in audience: if-if you have something
that goes to a hundred K and then it unGzips
to four Mgs, that seems like that should take
some time, but I could never find any indication
of how long that is possibly taking.
>>Kelly Norton: Right.
>>male in audience: Is that an event that
I could look at or-
>>Kelly Norton: So we don't have it as an
event. And-and I have to say that my experimentation
here is pretty small, but I have what, I will
tell you that I observed, from what I've observed,
it's insignificant.
>>male in audience: Okay.
>>Kelly Norton: The reason why it's insignificant,
in addition to just not taking a lot of total
time, is that most browsers actually have
additional threads, or in some cases additional
processes, that are part of the resource loading
stack. So in most cases it doesn't even happen
on your UI thread.
>>male in audience: Right.
>>Kelly Norton: So even if it did take a little
bit of time, it still has that asynchronous
feel apart from the actual UI so-
>>male in audience: Um.
>>Kelly Norton: The native, oh sorry.
>>male in audience: Sorry, and the native
JSON parsing do you think that that's gonna
help with the payload delivery, or is that
timing that you're looking at already native
browser JSON timing?
>>Kelly Norton: It's, so the native parsing
of JSON in the browsers is-is considerably
faster than what we have been doing.
>>male in audience: Yeah.
>>Kelly Norton: I-I think it's gonna actually
get faster though. I've already heard some
discussion-
>>male in audience: Right. Thank you.
>>Kelly Norton: around, about it. I mean.
So we're gonna run outa time. I-I'm, what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna break down my stuff,
and I'm gonna head towards the back so that
as the next session comes in, where, I'm not
standin' up in the front, and if you have
a question that you wanna ask me, then, then
meet me, meet me back there.
Cool.
Thanks, everyone.
[applause]